[Music]
dentures they're often used as comic
relief in movies and Pixar animated
shorts but they play a big part in the
daily lives of about 20 million people
in America and it's not just older
people wearing them but how exactly are
they made dentures have come a long way
this set took two fittings and was
shipped between two locations before it
was ready to wear the first thing to
know is that a full set of dentures has
a flesh-colored acrylic base that fits
over the gums the upper portion covers
the roof of your mouth and the lower is
a horseshoe shape that accommodates the
tongue now that we know the basics let's
learn how dentures are made first a
prosthodontist makes an impression to
capture the patient's upper and lower
gums a thick paste gets placed into the
patient's mouth for a few seconds while
the impression is still gooey it's
poured into a stone which acts as a cast
this cast is now a replica of the
patient's mouth which comes in handy
during the final stages of creating the
dentures in the meantime the patient
tries on different sets of dentures to
determine the size and color of their
soon-to-be teeth from there the
prosthodontist makes a few adjustments
to the cast next the cast of the mouth
is sent to the lab where the dentures
get made using the patient's cast as
reference the lab starts to create the
wax version of the gum line
[Music]
the teeth made of acrylic resin a
material that looks very similar to real
teeth are set in place minor touches get
made to the wax around the teeth then
get sent back to the prosthodontist
after the wax dentures are approved by
both the patient and the prosthodontist
for fit and look they're sent back to
the lab to finish the process the wax is
just temporary it gets replaced by an
acrylic which is more aesthetically
pleasing and realistic looking the lab
boils the dentures to get rid of the wax
portions holes are indented into the
teeth so the material can attach to it
then a machine called the IVA base
injects the acrylic liquid into the
molds to stick to the denture teeth the
dentures are cleaned up and polished
they're now ready for the patient
[Music]